a grandfather and homeless veteran
likely saved his friend's life while
losing his own
right now police say stephen colburn's
murderer may be living right here in the
valley
and they hope showing you video taken
moments before his death
solves the case for the first time our i
team's david charns is going back to the
crime scene
with the woman who survived
when i looked over at him he was like
boom boom
boom right on top of stephen lynn
prindle's life
changed in just under a minute i haven't
been over there i think it's time that i
this is her first time back on north tom
boulevard the spot where she parked her
car
to share a bite with her friend stephen
colburn right here this is where you
used to sleep
and he was harmless
colburn called this slab of pavement his
home
because he was just a homeless veteran
but he was my buddy
august 19 2019 the two are sitting in
prindle's car when a gunman walks up and
demands money
we looked at each other because we
basically don't really have any money
you know most of the time stephen might
have had 30 40 dollars in his top pocket
but he wasn't about to give it up this
grainy video from across the street
shows what happens next both get out of
the car
the gunman holding his weapon to
prindle's head
steven took off running the guy looked
and he looked again
and he took the gun away from my um
from my head and took off running jumped
over
a few of these bushes and was shooting
boom boom these photos from
investigators that night show
shell casings in the parking lot colburn
likely
saved his friend's life i'm sure he did
i'm sure he did stephen colburn a father
a grandfather an army veteran was 59.
he's sitting there with a friend
who's providing him food right i mean
this is a guy that has done nothing
wrong
metro lieutenant ray spencer says
there's no link between colburn and the
shooter
making this case more difficult to piece
together
and we're looking for such a generic
description i have a
black male in his late teens to early
20s that's a hard case to solve
i miss him i really do
prindle says she hopes somebody
remembers the story
maybe the gunman gloated about it and
she remembers this
one thing about the man who held a gun
to her head
and killed her friend very angry very
angry
all you just wanted the money that's it
investigators tell the i-team they
believe the gunman lived in the area
near where colburn was murdered just by
the north las vegas airport
he's described as a skinny black man
between 25
and 35 years old you can help solve this
case by submitting a tip anonymously
with the crime stoppers number you see
there on your screen or on their website
and they do offer a reward for
information
leading to a conviction i'm david charns
8 news now
and you can find this story right over
on eight newsnow dot com and inside our
free app
share it to help spread the word it is
right alongside last week's
i-team vegas unsolved